[Music]
good morning goldie
my name is guy and i live in free city
i have everything i need
[Music]
except one thing hey
excuse me hey
hey bud you ever think that there's got
to be more more than what
the stuff we do day after day literally
not once
today's gonna be different goldie what
are we looking at
who are you we ran into each other the
other day how did you find me i waited
outside by the murder train guy
i have to tell you something there is no
easy way to say this this world it's a
video game
i really want to kiss you is that weird
listen to me you're not real
wait you let who kiss you guy there's
not a button for that
oh he found the button
buddy if we're not real doesn't that
mean that nothing you do matters i am
sitting here
with my best friend trying to help him
get through a tough time
now if that's not real i don't know what
it is
millie i know this world is just a game
but this place these people that's all i
have
thanks guys who is this guy this
character in the video game free city
has been turning heads
by being the good guy who is blue shirt
guy you're absolutely right who is he
or she indeed this loser is ruining the
game man
i don't care if he's arnold freaking
schwartz invader
terminate him
we're doing great guy in two days the
game is gonna shut down
you this whole city they'll be gone what
if we can save it
[Music]
was that cool it felt really cool we
could change
our world but we have to fight together
i don't even know what's happening right
now
but i love it this is the first time
i've ever driven a car before
i really wish you'd mentioned that yeah
they seem nice
[Applause]
captain do you have any idea what those
markers are they look pretty ancient
the tracks end here it's definitely
bravo team they don't just disappear
ah where the hell are we that lightning
hit those markers and it took us
somewhere
wow guys
so what are we like guardians of the
galaxy now
on our six yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
this is officially above my paygrade
i don't care what those creatures are
you destroy them and close the gateway
i'm getting into our home
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
clever
give me some shell i gotcha
[Applause]
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
my whole life i trained to become a
guardian of the dragon gem
but this world has changed
[Music]
and its people are divided
now to restore peace i must find
the last dragon
my name is raya
[Music]
you're getting a little too big for this
bud
[Music]
you know what i don't understand how the
hell are you still alive
must've been a pretty bad fool the comet
you see in the sky right now
passes over the earth every six years
causes a portal
but when it's open we get a visitor from
a distant galaxy
the poet warrior in the sci-fi sense
the space man he comes here
looking for a fight with you
the chosen jiu-jitsu but if he doesn't
get it
he stays and he kills everything that
is alien politics 5 through 15.
now you are all
the chosen jiu jitsu fighters
but as long as you die bravely no one
else will have to
he's crazy like me
there's no honor in killing crazy
[Music]
i can fly too
we're back
hey where you going i thought we were
going fishing
you're welcome
[Music]
a sequel how original
my story begins when i was a young boy
you'll be comfy here your mama's all
wrong i'd do anything for her to be here
right now
grandma was a tough lady with a big
heart
and little by little she brought me out
of my sadness
[Music]
i didn't know it but there was a dark
shadow looming nearby
[Applause]
witches they're real
and they hate children welcome
what would you do if there were mice
learning all around us is so dead
i would call the exterminator you see
girls he would exterminate those brats
uh rats
we would exterminate the rats
that means the test is coming
ladies i have a plan hundred
to transform a child into a mouse
[Music]
[Music]
we'll never let you get away with your
filthy evil plot
who's gonna stop me doesn't matter who
you
are or what you look like as long as
somebody loves you
you wouldn't happen to be carrying
around a mouse on your person
now would you a mouse why on earth would
i be carrying around a mouse
[Music]
14 year ago i released movie film which
brought great shame to kazakhstan
but now i was instructed to return to
yankee land to carry out
secret missions i go to america
[Applause]
what do you say no it's not me
people may recognize my face i would
need
disguises this man sex criminal
no i'm no sex friend
i will take this to be a fat like
american man
yeah this is a good one where is his
crumb
what is problem officer that's somebody
that's strapped to the top of your car
it's in that passenger seat boss only
men and bears are allowed inside cars
i'm here to give my daughter as a gift
to someone close to the throne
i need dress with real sexy peels
uh this is a bag that just goes over the
dress
they're nice i really like this
let us present sandra jessica parker
drummond
i want this one with the baby on it
i have a baby inside me can you take it
though no we cannot
that's not what we do here i feel bad
because i was the one who put the baby
in her
did you ever put one in your daughter no
i did not
where is everybody they want everybody
to quarantine so they don't spread this
virus
could i stay in your home
i hope quarantine never ends
what is more dangerous this virus
or the democrat democrats democrats
killing some of the virus no you can't
see the virus no it's still there
if you think you see a virus like that
this makes the virus
sleepy and then when it's sleeping
the daddy has a lot to learn my daddy is
the smartest person in the whole flood
world
and while the risk of coronavirus
remains low as the president said
yesterday
we're ready for enemy michael penis
i brought the girl for you borah's
subsequent movie film
you pissed me now if you still alright
what do you prefer you fixed me in life
still
same time fist each other
[Music]
hey wait we gotta try it try what
calling the empty man where's the empty
man
if you're on a bridge and you find a
bottle you blow into it
and you think about the empty man
oh come on mindy how old are you it's on
the rest
on the first night you hear him and on
the second night you see him
and on the third night well on the third
night he finds you
he finds you
[Music]
you can hear him squirming his way into
your thoughts
like a disease and his message is
contagious
[Music]
no i cannot anybody missing a snowman
i got too confident there
what do you need a sense of self
i kind of look like a fernando
or a trevor not so sure about that
yeah i'm off to find my name
[Music]
stay together back together again
i'm having a bit of a crisis of identity
i think
true love
that's a gift unlike any other it's all
scary until you just do it
so why not just do it
[Music]
this is your captain welcoming you to
ymit airfly227
you remember those lessons i used to
give you you ready to give it a go
make sure that the horizon stays level
right here i'm going to turn off the
autopilot
look ma
[Laughter]
he's having a heart attack
we have no pilot the autopilot's broken
we have no idea where we are
neither of us can land a plane hello can
anyone hear me this is a distress call
man this is 227. you still got it in the
air so keep doing you're doing
holy [ __ ] look at i see the that
it's too big to go around you're gonna
have to play through it
that's our shot no going back let's get
off this plane
disney and pixar's seoul streaming on
disney plus december 25th
music is all i think about
from the moment i wake up in the morning
to the moment i fall asleep at night
i was born to play
it's my reason for living
hello
oh my goodness
hmm this weird the council
is a soul missing
is this heaven no is it h e
double hockey sticks how how hell quiet
coyote
no it's the great before this is where
new souls get their personalities
quirks and interest before they go to
earth here we are
don't worry you can't crush a soul here
that's what life on earth is for
oh it's my life
can you help me get back come on
this won't be a disaster that's for sure
you're out these dummy little song
and i'm gonna find you
[Music]
life is full of possibilities
[Music]
you just need to know where to look
[Music]
don't miss out on the joys of life
like uh pizza i can't smell
we can't we can't taste either all that
stuff is in your body
no smell no taste or touch see
okay i get it disney and pixar's soul
get ready your life is about to start
start streaming december 25th
okay all right let's do this i know it
feels fast
but it's nice isn't it to have a family
unit
come on in and meet the boys they're
really excited to meet you
[Music]
how you feeling about school you can
meet some new friends
i know why the caged bird sings wow
that is super nasty
[Music]
hey it happens to everyone he's made us
all cry at one point or another
you should come over after school
what is all this this is a ceremony
to celebrate you
why would you celebrate me because
you're out fourth
just in time for first period
this is all just a little crazy half the
battle of having powers is believing you
do
that's why covens have always been
important
[Music]
if we can do that what else can we do
we need to put a spell on timmy we don't
want to hurt him though right
she's right the number one rule of the
craft
if a person is a danger to herself or
others
they will be bound
i'm starting to get a little worried
sorry i was just hanging out with my
friends
we've gone too far was this just like
some game to you
i feel different
be careful a lot of weirdos out here we
are the weirdos mister
[Music]
this is your last careers lesson so does
anyone have a realistic career plan
tyson denzel what about you youtubers
i keep telling you all you've got to
keep things real jamie
jamie knew me what do you want to be
a performer
for a minute there i had such high hopes
for you
what is wrong with our boy you remember
when we was little
can we use flair dress up well for me
that's a game i don't want to stop
playing i'm done with this
i wanted a song so badly i got you
the cold empty morning
i don't think i've got a dad anymore
you've done nothing wrong jamie you
never did
so why do you want to be on the stage
i want to be a drag queen because it's
all i ever dream of
and when i close my eyes it's all i can
see
[Music]
if jamie wants to come to prom becomes
just just like all the other boys
you are a freak they made me feel so
ugly
i'm scared tomorrow you can't just be a
buying address jamie
obama dresses something to blaster
a drag queen should be feared you won't
believe the power it gives you
i don't just want to be one i have to be
one stop waiting for permission
[Music]
no mom
do you ever wish i were just normal
no
[Applause]
and you don't never know it your room's
so tidy i don't know how you do it i
don't have as many dresses as you do
i'm not gonna be home tonight it'd be
all right
[Music]
jimmy something happened tonight
you'll work out with cal where you're
gonna go who the hell is cal where is
eddie
i'm cow
[Music]
is eddie okay you know what he is but
he's a thief yes i know what eddie is
true is anybody looking
everyone's looking and they're looking
for you too
you're not to talk to anyone i've never
been on my own
wouldn't you
shut the kid up
[Applause]
[Music]
this was your i'm terry cal's wife
anyone can learn to shoot but what you
really need to figure out is
what you'll do when it's real
why did art show me how to use a gun i
just thought you should be prepared for
what comes next
what comes next
this is no place for a child
this can all be over
where i grew up it's another world from
this one my father was stuck in time a
little bit
what was he like he was religious
just differently like superstitious
what's up what's all done around these
parts we're going up for my daddy's you
know
they don't get many visitors up in those
houses
where am i you was in the plane accident
what about my family
[Music]
baby you were the only one
i need an ambulance ain't no hospital
within 50 miles of here
where you thank you is new york city
this it stands for you
whatever happens to it happens
to you i'm gonna fix you i'm gonna fix
you
[Applause]
[Music]
good
all right now tell us what you see
[Applause]
you may live in the city but you for
miss
[Music]
they got my family controlling everyone
in town
put you down
hey
[Music]
this is for your good
[Music]
i don't know what i'm doing wrong
i've lost my influence maybe it's time i
retired the coat
you still have it some kids with a deer
rifle put
two holes in the sleigh wanting me all i
have is a
loathing for a world that's forgotten
the united states military would like to
procure your services this is a one time
deal gentlemen
how are you mike nicole and the kids are
well i hope
where are you
[Music]
what's the job i'd like you to kill
santa claus
i'm looking for the fat man you can't be
serious
this is what people actually think about
christmas is a farce i am a joke
what's the purpose of your visit hunting
i'm gonna kill some things
there is a rising number of our youth
making poor decisions
what the big man's head severed heads
rot they mold they don't want his beard
i'm not shaving off a dead man's beard
your workers sure have healthy appetites
that's why elves live much longer than
humans and chris he knows the same
no it's a giving that keeps him young
i've come for your head fat man
[Music]
think i got this job because i'm fat and
jolly
[Music]
oh come on you sleep the fat man's got
his eye on you
kids hey whoa oh that's donna like it
wasn't blitzer should tear your package
clean off happy birthday daddy mac
well that one's wrapped up so nice it
must be from frank
electric shoe polisher next
i never knew why daddy mac was so mean
to uncle frank he was the kind of person
i wanted to be
smart and funny and considerate you're
going to be the person you decide to be
you're going to be the person everyone
else tells you all you get to choose
can i come visit you sometime
hi i'm frank smith oh my god beth nice
meeting you frank
tell me you're coming that's because he
doesn't know he doesn't know
oh well okay it's going to be very
exciting
how do you know uncle frank he's my
roommate
wally and i've lived together we have
for 10 years
never known anybody who was gay before
of course she had co-director of church
mr jersey he's so what religious
heart attack just
[Music]
you need me for this you know you do
no wally you're not coming we can take
turns driving are you the stupidest man
alive obviously look how i'm with
sometimes you always know you were guys
i always knew i was different
what's wrong wally
oh hey you forgot your razor you rented
a car
isn't it snazzy
[Music]
yeah i'd appreciate it if you didn't
tell anyone in the family
you want to stay by yourself in a motel
uncle frank's staying there too
so is wally who's wally what is the
relationship
between the two of you and the young
lady over there
oh she's my niece i'm his nephew that
doesn't sound right
that sounds wronger and wrong you're not
going to run away from this your whole
life
you need to be part of your family i
don't want to be a part of my family
so when you told me i should be what i
want to be that was just [ __ ]
that conversation changed my life
[Music]
tell me about this new boy at the store
hey what's your favorite song in this
you don't know what love is i am not
answering that is he cute
i didn't really notice that much
my band's playing night at nine if you
want to come
never met a girl who knows much about
music as you do
and television don't get me started i've
seen every episode of everything
how was it he's extraordinary
you don't have to go home but you can't
stay here can i walk you
life's too short to waste time on things
you don't absolutely love
but how do you know if you love
something absolutely
i guess when it's the only thing that
matters
[Music]
the band got off at a gig in paris come
with us on tour
i'm afraid i can't but i think you very
well could be the next john coltrane
what are you gonna be
wnat television talking about the
assistant producer position
are you married yes hey
producer's assistant's not the best job
for a housewife
why should i hire you because i didn't
know that a negro woman television
producer even existed
and all my life that is all i've ever
wanted to be
what are you doing in new york recording
an album
so good to see you you too it's been
awhile
you're working you're not being a very
good hostess and what will people say
i can't be the woman of your dreams
while also trying to be the woman of my
own
i guess i just wanted you to be happy
even if i couldn't be a part of your
life pleasant experiences ahead don't
pass it back
we'd like to hear some christmas carols
bob stein
last christmas me and bob worked on the
streets
[Music]
happy christmas i thought you could use
some christmas cheer
there's a lot of things i could use
right now getting my gas and hot water
back on
[Music]
that cat does not look happy to me
[Music]
can you control your dog we wanted to
chat to you about a couple of concerns
you can't take them away from me
if a guy who works on the street is
being separated from his cat at
christmas
it's got to be done by the book
you've got to help me i'm threatening to
take bob away
because i should anyone who knows the
man and the cat get in touch
you have proved your love a hundred
times over it's not normal for a cat to
be out in the streets james gives bob
the choice
to stay at home or go out with him and
every day
bob goes with him i dreamt of snow
back when i wasn't why is it always
about you james what so good
breaking they took everything
angels are all around us if we just know
where to look merry christmas
merry christmas
[Music]
christmas isn't a season it's a feeling
[Music]
whatever form your family takes
[Music]
that's what christmas is about
get up here you big lump no one must
know there are dragons in the battle
fire drake stay out of trouble what was
that
humans i've always told you they're the
worst what will they do when they find
them
the rim of heaven huh a paradise
for dragons we could go there and lead
everyone to safety how are you planning
to get that
i've got wings haven't i inspired by
cornelia funka's best-selling book
so genius where do we start
hi you're him
yeah climb aboard dragon rider
[Music]
golf and eating dragons
i just saw a juicy silver dragon
hunger for a silver dragon let's get out
of here
at us both roaring
many have searched but no one has found
the rim of heaven who's hungry now's not
the time for
impressment i'm trying to be mystical
it was an arranged marriage you are much
more than you think you are
follow your heart and the truth will
come to you ready
ready join a gang of unlikely friends
on a magical quest you want some of this
you
were a tiger
they're going to be chapati yep
dragon rider so we have two neck
partners some more
butt kicks
coming soon
[Music]
you